Narrator: Tonight,
on a special "Shark Tank,"
the next generation
of entrepreneurs
try to land a deal
in our millennials episode.
‐What?
‐No.
‐Oh!
‐Hold on to your kombucha.
Narrator:
But they'll quickly find out
that it's not so easy
in the deep end
when you swim
with the sharks.
Millennials are buying it,
right?
Millennials need
a social cause to get behind.
Everybody has
a social cause now.
I can see some of you
aren't buying it.
What would you do
for $375,000?
‐I'm gonna offer you 400K.
‐I'll make the same offer.
O'Leary: Oh, come on.
I don't want to go through
all this.
Does this mean
you're not countering to us?
I'm not even interested
in negotiating, guys.
We really feel like
you'll be kicking yourself
later for not getting in.
You know what? I know we'll
remember this moment together.
♪♪
I'm Brandon.
I'm Steven.
And I'm Bruno.
And we're the owners
of Sand Cloud.
We love the beach,
and we used to go to the beach
all the time
right after work.
One of these days,
we woke up on the beach
super uncomfortable
and looked at each other
and had this idea of putting
a pillow inside a beach towel.
And that's when
we first came up with
our million‐dollar idea,
the pillow towel.
We created the product and tried
selling it on the beach,
and that's when we realized
it was a total fail.
Nobody wanted it.
‐Hey. How's it going, guys?
‐What's going on?
We took this opportunity
and talked to
every single person
on the beach to figure out
exactly what they wanted.
And that's when
Sand Cloud was born.
As millennials,
having a business
with a social impact
is everything to us.
So we decided to donate 10% of
profits to protect marine life.
Have you guys seen
our numbers today?
We've risked everything.
We moved in together,
we sold our cars,
because there's no other option.
This is it.
Aschidamini:
It's not just about us.
It's about making a difference
in the environment
and actually making
a difference in the world.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Brandon.
I'm Steven.
And I'm Bruno.
And we're the owners
of Sand Cloud.
Today, we're seeking
an investment of $200,000
in exchange for
8% of our company.
We live just steps away
from one of the most
beautiful beaches
in San Diego.
It was here
that we realized
it was time for a long‐awaited
change to the standard towel.
Towels, since their inception,
are inherently plain.
‐Unimaginative.
‐Oh, my God.
‐Oh! [ Laughs ]
‐Yeah, baby. That's it!
‐Boring!
‐I didn't even catch that.
‐Wow.
‐And worse yet,
not so wonderful.
[ Laughter ]
What are you thinking?
‐Oh, you guys!
‐Oh!
You think there's
a chance in hell
you're getting 200 grand
from me?
[ Laughter ]
I'm out.
We knew that it was time to
introduce some new options...
‐Yeah.
‐... for a new generation.
And that's why
we started Sand Cloud.
Our unique
and vibrant patterns
will ensure that you
turn heads wherever you go.
All of our towels
are handcrafted
from the finest
Turkish cotton,
making them both lightweight
and multi‐functional.
Leibel: These perfect gifts
can be used at the beach,
as a decorative tapestry,
or even as a stylish scarf
in the winter.
Literally, the possibilities
are endless.
But, most importantly,
our towels connect people
to a bigger purpose.
With every
Sand Cloud purchased,
we donate to preserve
our oceans and marine life.
In fact, we want
to show you a video
of one of our charity partners
releasing sea lions
back into the ocean...
Cuban: Aw, that's great.
Good for you guys.
...after rescuing them
earlier this year.
John: That's great.
Sharks, we are not just
looking for money today.
We are looking for a mentor to
help guide us to the next level.
Now, which one of you Sharks
wants to wrap up in a Sand Cloud
and help us make a difference?
Now Bruno's gonna go
around the room
and pass out
some samples for you.
‐Thank you. Lori.
‐Thank you.
Here's our
Baja Beach Blanket.
This is our
best‐selling towel.
Cool.
Our Wanderlust.
‐Which one?
‐The Wanderlust.
Tie‐dye.
So, Brandon,
it's very thin.
‐Yeah.
‐It ‐‐ This ‐‐
I wouldn't think
this would make a good towel
after I got out of the water.
Right. Well, those are all
actually handmade in Turkey
from fine Turkish cotton,
actually all in villages
in Turkey by families.
So, it's really good quality,
and that's why we charge
$47 for it, because ‐‐
But it feels like a wrap
as opposed to a towel.
Yeah, 'cause, I mean, maybe it's
just how we're conditioned...
Yeah. It feels like
a scarf a little bit more.
...but, look, I started
my own company.
With the first commission check,
the first thing I did
was buy nice, thick,
fluffy towels,
because they just feel
so luxurious.
‐Right.
‐Actually, yeah,
when we first
started our company,
the first thing
we wanted to do,
we went to the towels that
were thicker and luxurious,
and when we tested the market
by selling one by one by two
at the beach, we found out
that people wanted
something different,
and they wanted something
that was easy to carry
in their backpack,
easy to fit in their purse.
That's fair enough.
So, this is more as
a beach product for the beach,
as opposed to in your home
in your ‐‐ in your bathroom.
It feels more like
a wrap, though, like a sarong.
Yeah. So, the great thing
about these is because ‐‐
you know, because of
the lightweight material,
it doubles as a sarong.
And what we've seen
a lot is,
people hang it up
in their house as a tapestry.
I could see that.
‐So ‐‐
‐How much is this?
That one is
actually $47.
‐$47?
‐Yow!
And what's your cost?
Our cost on that is $10,
so we have an 80% margin.
‐Wow.
‐Dang, you're proud.
Doesn't he like that?
‐People will pay 50 bucks
for this because it's really
about the whole lifestyle,
give back...
‐Right.
‐...baby seal.
‐Exactly.
We see ourselves
as the next NEXCOMs of the sea.
‐Sure.
‐Because millennials need
a social cause to get behind
in order to support you.
‐Are you selling on ‐‐
‐Well, the only thing is
that everybody has
a social cause now.
Every‐‐ 100% of millennials
that come in selling,
it's all about cause.
Probably 50%. Right.
The three of us, we own
100% of the company.
Good for you.
We've been in business
for about two and a half
years now.
Our first year in business,
we did $30,000 in sales.
Year two,
we did $430,000.
And this year, so far to date,
we've done over $1.6 million,
and we're on track
for $3 million.
‐Good for you guys.
‐All right.
‐What are gonna make ‐‐
‐Well, now we're at
massive sales.
What are you gonna make
on the $3 million?
On the $3 million,
we'll make $800,000.
Why only $800,000
when you have 80% margins?
Because we invest a ton
back into our brand.
So, you guys, it seems
that the main focus of this
is as a beach towel, and I look
at it as not a beach towel,
but more as a wrap
and a scarf.
So, I don't think I would really
be the right partner for you,
because we have
completely different thoughts
on what
the product's use is.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
‐Thanks a lot.
‐Thanks for your time, Lori.
Appreciate it.
‐What's the $200,000 for?
So, the $200,000, the one area
that we need help with
is rebuilding our website
and optimizing it.
Cuban:
And who's doing that?
Do you hire somebody to do it,
or is it somebody internally?
We ‐‐ We grind it out.
We learned to do
everything ourselves.
And how much
are you spending per day,
and is it mostly Facebook?
We tend to do campaigns.
We spend all our budget
in a short period of time,
like one month
or a month and a half.
So, during summer,
we spent
a quarter million dollars
in advertising.
Over what period of time?
Uh, over 90 days.
Less than 90 days.
‐All on ‐‐ All on Facebook?
‐Yeah.
Okay, so ‐‐ So, $2,500,
$3,000 a day, basically.
Yes. It turned into
over $1 million in sales
and a quarter million
in profit.
Okay, so you‐you're doing
3X or 4X basically?
‐Yes.
‐That's not bad.
That should be generating
a lot of cash.
We do have cash
in the bank.
Uh, we have over $300,000
in the bank right now.
There you go. Okay.
And we have
$160,000 inventory
that we built finally.
Okay, guys, I'll ‐‐
I'll make you an ‐‐
I'm gonna make you
an offer.
It needs to be
worthwhile for me,
and it needs to be
worthwhile for you.
So, I'm gonna offer you 400K,
but I need 25%,
so we're all
in the game together.
Okay. So, uh, there's
three of us
and, you know, we own 100%
of the company,
and the equity's already
split three ways.
Uh‐huh.
And we really want to have
some skin in the game,
as well.
Uh ‐‐ Uh, we think that 25%
is a little more
than we want to give away.
Okay.
So, um, we would like
to hear what the other Sharks
have to offer before
we give you an answer.
I'm out.
Ooh.
Yeah, so, I have
300K for 25%.
That's less good.
Hey, that's why
I didn't say anything
in your best interest
when he had that offer,
but you ‐‐ you know,
you three musketeers
dropped the fourth one
for whatever reason.
So, we want to counter.
What's your counter?
So, our counter is $200,000
for 10%.
‐Ouch.
‐You asked for $200,000 for 8%.
We're nowhere in the same
universe. I'm out.
So, I've listened
to your cash flow,
which is quite impressive.
We're hustlers, Kevin.
We're here to make a deal.
We want ‐‐ We were looking
for a Shark to help us.
You went up a whole 2%,
and you're making a deal.
Do you pay ‐‐ You guys don't
take anything out of the company
because you're basically funding
your inventory as you go
and spending it on Facebook.
‐Right.
I would do this deal.
I'll give you 200K for 15%,
but I've got to participate
in distributions.
You got to start
paying yourselves.
So, we're partners,
and I'm the smallest partner.
That will still take me
three and a half years
to get my money back.
It's not great.
I mean, that the problem.
‐So, your offer?
‐So, your offer is $200,000
for 15%?
Yeah.
All right, guys.
I'll make the same offer.
I got to tell you, I don't
really believe in it as a towel.
I don't get it,
but I made an investment
in a similar company,
ugly Christmas sweaters.
‐Yeah.
‐They're doing exactly
what you're doing,
they're building
a lifestyle brand online.
They were doing $600,000.
We did $17 million last year.
I've learned
that business inside out.
Doesn't matter what I think
about the product.
You guys are killing it.
I say they don't.
I say they do.
‐So ‐‐
‐What do you guys want to do?
Robert, we'll acc‐‐
we'll accept your deal.
‐All right!
‐$200,000.
‐Yes!
‐Thanks, guys.
‐Yeah, we're excited.
‐Awesome.
I didn't see it,
but the more you talked...
‐Thank you, guys.
‐... I‐I got it.
and I got the brand.
‐You're gonna see it.
We are gonna be the next ‐‐
‐Robert beats Kevin again.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐I love it.
Thank you, Sharks.
We really appreciate it.
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Dude!
[ Laughs ]
‐Nice.
‐Hell, yeah.
‐Dude, that was so perfect.
Getting a deal
with Robert today is amazing
because we really wanted
a Shark to help us
with those high‐level decisions
that we come across
almost every single day,
and we really need him
to take us
to the next level.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank is
what the entrepreneurs believe
is a new generation of
nutritional supplements.
Hey, Sharks. I'm Will,
and I'm from sunny San Diego.
And I'm Ron from
beautiful Santa Barbara.
We are Ora Organic,
and we're seeking $375,000
in exchange for
5% of our company.
♪♪
Greiner: Whoa.
Sharks, have you ever
thought about
how your supplements
are made?
Like, the actual stuff
in the actual capsule?
Well, hold on to your kombucha,
because you wouldn't believe
some of the stuff
that's used to make some
"nutritional" supplements.
Chef Ron,
let's break it down.
Starting with Vitamin C.
It comes from oranges, right?
Wrong.
It comes from corn extract
processed with acetone.
Yep. The same stuff
as nail polish remover.
‐Ew.
‐No.
‐Really?
‐Iron.
Sulfuric acid.
‐No!
‐What?!
‐Oh, come on.
‐No.
Protein.
Synthetic growth hormone.
‐Ugh.
‐Ew!
‐Ew.
Out of a syringe.
‐Omega‐3.
‐Yep. Fish guts.
No!
Greiner: Oh! Don't kill it,
don't kill it.
‐Ohh!
‐No!
‐And, dare I ask, Vitamin D?
‐Ew.
Oh, Gosh.
Bring out the lamb.
What?
No.
[ Laughter ]
John: That's not a lamb.
That's Kevin's cat.
‐No!
‐Don't worry, Sharks.
I'll give you
the money.
Don't worry, Sharks.
We're not putting the cat ‐‐
I mean, lamb ‐‐
in the pot.
But that's right.
Vitamin D comes from
the grease secreted
by a sheep's oil glands.
‐No.
‐Ohh, seriously?
So, Sharks, would you
rather consume this...
or this?
[ Harp strings play ]
It's all about Ora.
[ Angelic voices vocalizing ]
‐Not ‐‐ not that aura.
‐Oh.
Together: This Ora.
Smelko: These little bad boys
come from plants,
just like the food that you eat,
not artificial chemicals.
Just good, old‐fashioned food.
And just 'cause
it's healthy doesn't mean
it tastes like
rabbit food.
That's why I'm here.
So, Sharks, would you rather
have artificial supplements
or Ora Organic's delicious,
chef‐designed nutrients
from real food?
Who's ready
for their first course?
‐Yeah. Let's try it.
‐We are.
♪♪
‐Thank you.
‐Here we go.
And here's your menu
for tonight.
‐Thank you.
‐You're welcome.
So, for your first
course today,
we have Ora's organic,
uh, pineapple spray.
Right in the mouth?
Right into the mouth.
‐And it has Omega‐3.
‐What ‐‐ What vitamin
are we getting in this?
‐It has Omega‐3, 600 mg,
and the best part ‐‐
there's nothing fishy about it.
That's because
we use microalgae.
The second course is the one
with the strawberry garnish.
That's Ora Organic's
multivitamin.
‐Wow.
‐This is so good.
It does contain
over 25 different fruits,
vegetables,
and super foods.
And, Chef Ron,
what's the last one?
The ‐‐
The last one, that's our,
uh, super‐food protein.
We have ‐‐ We've used it
in a baking recipe here.
It's our organic, vegan,
uh, coconut truffle.
‐Incredible.
‐Now, wait a minute.
Are you actually
selling this
for people to eat
to get their vitamins?
So, the truffle,
we're not selling, but ‐‐
We will be soon.
Man, this is good.
On the truffle,
I'm gonna give it a 9.26.
‐Oh, wow.
So, this is
what you're selling?
Yes. So, we're selling
an Omega‐3 spray,
a multivitamin powder,
and a multivitamin capsule,
as well as
a super‐food protein powder.
So, I use that to
make these great things?
‐Absolutely. Yes.
‐I got it.
Ron, tell us a little bit
about yourself.
So, uh, I'm a chef,
as you can see.
Um, growing up,
my parents owned and operated
six restaurants, so I've been
a foodie all of my life.
But my uncle died
of a heart attack,
uh, when he was 55.
My grandfather had
triple‐bypass surgery.
Wow.
And none of
these health problems
really occurred until
they moved over to the U. S.
Where were they from?
They were from Taiwan.
And I put two and two together,
and it was the diet.
So, I quit my job
in tech consulting
and dedicated myself
towards healthy living.
‐How did you meet Will?
‐So, we are actually, uh,
freshman‐year roommates
in college at U. C. Berkeley.
Professionally, uh,
I come from a background of
strategy and operations
consulting,
um, for life sciences
and healthcare companies.
So, Will, do you have
customers today?
Uh, we do.
To date, um,
in under 10 months, we've sold
over $400,000,
about $415,000.
‐That's very good.
‐Very good.
‐That's not horrible.
‐Where are you selling?
‐We've sold ‐‐
‐Online mainly.
‐Just online?
It's been
our only channel.
How much did you
sell last month?
Um, in the first seven months,
we sold like gangbusters
and starting
selling out of product.
We went from basically
$0 to $65,000 a month.
‐Why weren't you sourcing more?
‐So, you only made
a limited amount
and then you started to sell out
and then you couldn't
manufacture again
or take a wait‐list order?
Uh, so, we ‐‐
we did, actually.
We brought in
a little bit of money,
um, on a convertible note.
We raised that quickly.
How much?
We raised $150,000.
What valuation
did you raise that on?
That was for a $2.2 million
post‐money valuation.
There's a lot
of people doing this.
Highly, highly competitive.
I thought that you had
a food‐based product
with a different delivery ‐‐
online or something.
It's not something I use.
I'm not the Shark.
I'm out.
Thank you so much, Robert.
$415,000 in sales in 10 months
is great. It really is.
But you're valuing
the company at $7.5 million.
Why do you think
that a Shark is gonna join in
for 5% for $375,000?
Yeah, um, so, the fast growth,
the size of the industry,
as you guys know 30 to 40 ‐‐
‐All right.
‐It's very competitive.
Okay, so, as soon as people say
the size of the industry,
that's an indicator that you
don't have enough information.
That number is ridiculous.
You're just unrealistic.
I'm out.
I'm your customer.
I'm into healthy,
natural, organic.
I'm so up on all of these
things, but this bottle,
if I were to walk down
the store aisle in Whole Foods,
I feel like this is not
going to work for you,
because when you have
a multivitamin,
it's so tiny here where it says
"Men's plant‐based
multivitamin."
I have to be drawn to this
bottle to pay attention to it.
So I'm concerned
about your marketing.
Sorry. I'm out.
Look, you know, when I heard
you talk about being a chef,
what I immediately thought of,
"Okay, they're gonna
actually create foods,
maybe rather than selling
them at retail,
they'll sell them to, you know,
Plated and Blue Apron."
That, to me, is a win.
Being dependent on just
being a brand
and trusting that you're unique,
that's a stretch.
I'm out.
So, Kevin,
you're the only one left.
So, this deal is challenged
by the competition.
I love it's on trend,
et cetera.
I like the fact you have sales,
but getting share
is gonna be really hard,
and I feel the valuation
you put on it at
$7.5 million is extreme.
There's nothing wrong
with reaching for the stars,
but I'm a Shark.
I'm not just any investor.
That's also good news for you.
Because I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I'm gonna give you $375,000.
I want 20%.
Ohh!
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Will and Ron
are seeking $375,000
for 5% of their
natural‐supplement company,
Ora Organic.
But Kevin wants
a bigger piece of the pie.
I'm gonna give you
the $375,000.
I want 20%.
Ohh!
I'm not even interested
in negotiating, guys.
This is not an easy deal
by any means.
I'll do that, or you can pass.
You choose.
So, you're firm,
$375,000, 20%?
I‐I'm ‐‐ Look ‐‐
We're not gonna take
a down‐round.
Meet ‐‐
It's not a down‐round.
Meet us at ‐‐
You've got a Shark.
It's an up‐round.
You know that music
that you had...
♪ Aaaaaaaah ♪
You go back with that.
In terms of valuation, um,
because of the traction
that we've seen,
we would be willing
to consider a counter dropping
our valuation to $5 million.
I'll be flexible this way.
If I were to agree
to the last round,
to go back in a round
that you actually had
a trigger price at $2.2 million,
I would do 17%.
That is the match to that.
I've already done the math.
‐Ooh.
‐So, if you want to bring me
into the $2.2 million
round valuation,
I'll do $375,000 there
at 17%.
That's it, guys.
We would really love to find
a way to bring you onboard.
I just gave you a path.
As we look at where
our company is, our projections,
what we are going to sell
in the next 12 months ‐‐
Guys, I‐I've never seen
a forecast I haven't
liked, ever.
They're always fantastic.
Then I deal with the reality
with all my entrepreneurs
about how tough it is
to grow a business.
He's at 17%.
Where are you at?
What would you do
for $375,000?
So, we would consider,
um, because we want
to scale quickly,
uh, if ‐‐ if you...
All right. Stop selling.
... if you would be willing
to do $500,000
in exchange for 10%?
Not doing that.
And I admire what you're doing,
and I like your product,
but I just bring too much value,
and I know what I'm worth.
‐What do you say?
‐What are you gonna do?
It's ‐‐ It's a shame,
because we're gonna grow
at the rate that
we really feel like you'll be
kicking yourself later
for not getting in.
We're going to Sprouts,
we're talking to Whole Foods,
we're going to be
in the big‐box retailers.
It's ‐‐ It's a matter ‐‐
It's only a matter of time.
Guys, I have many companies
that are going through
the process you are.
The rollout
to Whole Foods national
is gonna take three years.
It's a long journey.
You know what?
I'm okay if you say no,
but I know we'll remember
this moment together
about a year from now,
and you'll say, "I wish I'd done
that deal with Mr. Wonderful."
I'll do the deal
at $375,000 for 17%,
which tags on to
your $2.2 million round.
You've got good logic to do it.
You don't have to.
Please decide.
So, thank you all
for your feedback
and for the conversation.
We think we have
far too good of a product
and have come too far
in such a fast amount of time,
and the upside is huge.
Uh, so, we politely
and respectfully
decline your offer.
That's fine. Thank you
very much for your time.
Thank you.
Mr. Wonderful is
absolutely going to regret,
uh, this ‐‐ this decision
and the offers that he made.
Um, he's really not going to be
able to sleep well at night
after he sees that
we're just gonna continue
to make the kind
of progress we already have.
Oh, my God. Talk about
overselling themselves.
‐Divas.
‐I agree, but the pricing
made sense at the last round
of $2.2 million,
because nothing's happened.
Kevin, Kevin.
The only certainty is that
they're not gonna listen.
Then, Mark, you know
what I have to say?
They are dead to me.
Narrator: In Season 6,
David Heath and Randy Goldberg
made a deal with Daymond John
for Bombas,
their sock company
with a social mission.
$200,000 for 17.5%.
You have a deal.
‐We'll take the deal.
‐My gold!
Narrator: Let's see
how they're doing now.
Today is Veteran's Day,
and Bombas team
is at a residence for homeless
veterans here in New York City,
and we've got
a big announcement.
What's up, guys?
Daymond's gonna join us
for the occasion, and we
couldn't be more excited.
We've built a business where
for every pair of socks we sell,
we donate a pair
to somebody in need.
11% of the American
homeless population
is made up of veterans.
That's almost 40,000 American
vets out on the streets.
We are here to support
the V. A. to bring more comfort
and stability
to our homeless veterans.
They've served us, and now,
we're here to help serve them.
We are officially
partnering with the V. A.
to donate a pair of socks
to every homeless veteran
in the United States.
Goldberg: Along with the socks,
each recipient will receive
an information card about
how to access the V. A. benefits
that they've earned
and how to exit homelessness
as quickly as possible.
Before "Shark Tank,"
we had only $450,000 in sales.
After "Shark Tank,"
we've had over $14.5 million
in total sales.
And the best part is,
we've donated almost
2 million pairs of socks
to those in need,
and we expect to double that
by the end of 2017.
Thank you for your service,
brother.
Every time I'm involved
with events like these,
it reminds me about what
entrepreneurship really is.
It's about paying it forward,
it's about empowering.
This is absolutely
one of my most successful
"Shark Tank" investments.
They're making money,
and they're changing lives.
The best part of our job
is being able
to interact
with the community.
Being able to see
the smile on their face
is what truly drives us
as a business every single day.
Thank you for your service!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a business set to capitalize
on a growing trend.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Abby Speicher.
I'm from Scranton, Pennsylvania,
and my company is DartDrones.
I am seeking $300,000 in
exchange for 10% of DartDrones.
Sharks, drones are cool,
aren't they?
They're the ultimate tech toy.
You get the thrill
of piloting something
while, at the same time,
capturing amazing
aerial photographs.
Unfortunately, shots like these
don't happen all the time.
Far too often,
you get something like this.
[ Laughter ]
Greiner: Oh, no.
‐Ooh!
‐Oh!
[ Laughter ]
This is embarrassing
and expensive.
I see this all the time, and it
certainly has happened to me.
People love drones,
but they don't know
how to fly them properly.
They fly where they shouldn't
or they crash into objects.
I believe that people should get
the most out of their drone,
and that's why new drone pilots
turn to DartDrones.
DartDrones is the only
national drone training school
in the country.
We offer
custom‐tailored courses,
whether you're
an aspiring drone entrepreneur
or a recreational user
just flying for fun.
Our expert flight instructors
have over 250 years
of combined aviation experience
and provide expert,
hands‐on flight instruction.
We are the leading experts
in getting you launched,
trained, and certified
on your drone.
Sharks, who's ready
to take off with DartDrones?
Can we try it?
You can try it.
So ‐‐
I've never flown a drone.
Oh, okay. Good.
So, when you fly, um,
to turn on the props,
what you're gonna do
is put both fingers in
and they'll turn on.
So, the props will spin,
and you can just wait.
It's not gonna take off.
This, uh, makes you
go up or down.
So, you'll go up,
and it'll go pretty quickly,
and then, fly with this stick,
and you'll go ‐‐
You're just gonna go up,
come over to the landing pad,
and then, to land,
you'll start to go down.
And then, once you're done
and you're at the ground,
you'll hold down this stick,
and the props will turn off.
I believe in you.
Is it ready?
Yep, so don't crash into the TV.
This is so cool.
[ Laughs ]
Okay. Ready?
All right.
This is gonna be good.
Robert is now gearing it up,
he's pushing his thumbs inward
the wrong way,
and it's not working.
Yeah.
Ah.
‐Just one side, right?
‐This is why you need training.
‐So, okay. Perfect.
‐That's right.
Now he's got some traction.
‐So, now, let go.
‐Here we go.
‐Is it still on?
Okay, so the props
are spinning.
Thank goodness it's tethered,
because men are gonna die.
And then, you go up.
Okay, enough. Ready?
Then, with this one,
come over.
Awesome!
And then you're coming down,
and then land.
So, come down, down,
and then you'll hold it down.
O'Leary: Bring it home,
Robert. Bring it home.
Can you hit the middle of the ‐‐
‐Oh!
‐Oh, no!
Oh, he's pulling
the tether. Oh.
Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
‐Come on, Rob.
‐I got this.
[ All cheering ]
Nice. That's awesome.
Now put it back
on the table.
‐Whoo. Okay.
‐You seemed way more nervous
than I did.
‐I was nervous.
I was really nervous
for you.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Okay.
‐Nervous for him.
‐That was really cool.
I am buying a drone.
So, it seems easy,
but, unfortunately,
a lot of people crash.
Like, I told you to just
touch it ever so slightly,
and you would, like,
fly right into a tree.
I would've definitely
done that.
If you didn't tell me
to do it that lightly ‐‐
Yes. Oh, you would've
been through the roof.
I mean, it's immediate.
Exactly.
Are you able to train people to
fly it when it's out of sight?
That's my question.
So, that's the goal.
I mean, the goal is for you
to be able to fly
looking at the monitor and not
looking up at the drones.
How long does it take
to get somebody
to actually be able
to do that?
How many days?
So, right now what we have
is a one‐day class
that we have both
hobbyists coming into
and also people looking to fly
it commercially, and it ‐‐
And how much
is that class?
It's $400 for a full day,
eight hours, in person.
‐$400?
‐And that's one school
in Pennsylvania?
No. We have 22 flight
instructors across the country.
‐Wow.
‐So we're teaching in 27 cities.
We rent hotel meeting rooms
or schools or local
fire training locations.
We make sure that they have
a huge field next door,
so they rotate
from indoor to outdoor.
What are your sales?
So, we've been
operating for 18 months,
and we've made $520,000.
That's pre‐‐, that's after
you paid everybody?
‐That's awesome.
‐Is that revenue?
‐No. Sales. Sales.
And what will it be
next year?
We're on track to make
between $900,000
and $1.2 million depending ‐‐
‐And how much will you make
pre‐tax, after
you've paid everybody?
So, right now, we're
spending all of our profit
on building new curriculum.
So, every time we have profit,
we're making ourselves better.
You're not
profitable yet.
We could be if we just
gave up on new curriculum.
We could just sit back
and enjoy it.
‐And why ‐‐ why ‐‐
‐Why do you need that $3‐‐
What do you need
that $300,000 for, Abby?
To build curriculum.
What we notice in our classes
is that people in our classes
were actually commercial users,
so their company sent them
or their police
or fire department sent them.
So, what we have made,
this big shift to now not focus
so much on hobbyists and focus
more on commercial users.
How did you start
to do this?
Like, what ‐‐ what
is your background?
I was born to be
an entrepreneur.
I started my first company
when I was 17.
We manufactured purses
in Ghana, Africa,
and then sent them here
to be sold
and then funded kids' education
while in Ghana.
At the end of college, I knew
I wanted to be an entrepreneur.
I wanted to do something
really innovative,
and I‐I didn't know if the ‐‐
the purses were really for me.
I‐I've only ever owned
like three purses.
[ Laughter ]
Um, so, like, I wasn't really
a purse person.
I decided I wanted to go to
Babson for the MBA program.
Um, so, I applied and I got in,
so I was the youngest person
in my class, and I ended up
graduating,
went in their B. E. T. A.
Business Plan Competition
that happens every year,
and I graduated
with the Entrepreneurship Award
and a few other awards
for entrepreneurship.
‐Good for you.
Do you have
competition with this,
or you the only ones
doing it?
Not really. So, we're
the only national one.
Um, the only other
companies out there offer ‐‐
One offers
an unaccredited PhD.,
which I don't really get,
and the other one, um,
they're ‐‐ they're like $4,000
for a seven‐day course.
What about colleges?
Are any colleges or community
colleges offering this?
Um, they have approached us
to license our curriculum out,
so we're working on
curriculum again.
Which is exactly where
I was going, yeah.
‐Wow.
‐Yes.
John: So, drones last year
were the highest‐returned
product in history.
Over 60% of the drones purchased
were returned because...
They were crashed?
... Dad comes home with a drone,
he flies it around,
it ‐‐ it hits the cat,
the cat's shredded,
and mom says,
"Get that drone and you
the hell out the house," right?
Yes. Right.
If you had a relationship
with Toys "R" Us,
a hobby shop,
or whatever the case is...
Yes.
... it reduces the amount
of drones coming back to them.
Right.
It upsells you.
Have you done
anything like that?
Yes. So we do partner
with hobby shops in the area,
and we pay them if they ‐‐
an affiliate fee
if they promote us.
Yeah.
So, that has been
very successful.
It's one of our more
successful marketing tracks.
And we believe that the industry
is going to start to build
some serious partnerships.
A big one is just going
for the main manufacturer.
Like, literally, if we just had
a little business card
in every single box...
‐Great idea.
‐Which would be really smart.
...that's all I need is,
someone, get me
the business card in there,
and then we're
good to go forever.
‐Right.
So, really, it comes down
to customer acquisition.
Yes.
That's your challenge.
Getting the connection,
getting your name out there.
You need to find a better way
to bring in customers,
and you want to build
the authority
that you are the brand.
Yes.
And you're trying
to figure out the balance
and the best way
to do that
without having to spend
just a fortune.
Right. But, with a Shark,
we would be that authority.
You want to accelerate it...
Yes.
...and just get it through
the media and P. R. and all that.
Yeah.
So, guys, I've listened.
I've heard enough.
I'll, uh ‐‐ I'll start
the game off here.
I don't think
you're worth $3 million.
Why?
I've been in
your business before.
You know what?
I do, all right, so ‐‐
Okay, but let me make an offer.
You can make a counter offer.
That's fine.
All right.
I'll give you the $300,000
for 15%.
‐Okay.
‐It's not that far off.
That's close.
And I'll give you
the 300K for 10%,
but I don't want
to go through all this.
If you want to work with me,
say yes.
And if not, I'll defer
to everybody else.
Done.
Whoo.
What did he just offer?
I didn't even ‐‐
I took it.
[ Laughs ]
We're best friends.
What did he just say?
He gave her what
she was asking for.
Okay. Thank you.
Thanks.
That's how you do a deal!
‐That's not a deal.
‐That's how you lose 300 grand.
Speicher: I feel awesome.
I can't believe
we got that deal.
It was perfect.
I mean, this just took us
to the next level.
But you just gave her
exactly what she asked for.
W‐Why would you ‐‐ Why would
you give her what she wanted?
She would've had flexibility.
Because the competition
isn't just with her.
It's with you guys, too.
I always hear people say,
"Oh, Mark just took the deal,
took the deal."
Here's what I learned.
He said he didn't want
to negotiate against us,
because he's afraid.
[ Laughs ] Oh, yeah.
That's why ‐‐
‐That's exactly right.
‐That's a good point.
I was afraid of having
to listen to you guys.
[ Imitates chicken clucking ]
[ Laughs ]
Narrator: Next up
is a business that seeks
to help the animals
that inspired their company.
All right.
[ Laughs ]
Hi, Sharks.
My name's Nathan Coleman.
And my name
is James Brooks.
We are
the Elephant Pants...
Together: [ New York accents ]
From Brooklyn, New York.
Shout out of Brooklyn.
We're seeking $500,000
for a 10% share
of our company.
Our awesome company.
[ Chuckles ]
James, hit them
with the motto.
Save elephants.
Feel good.
So, how do we save
these elephants?
We actually gave them
pants to wear.
Our mascot Ellie over here
is wearing one of
our newest styles.
[ Chuckles ]
Okay. I can see some of you
aren't buying it.
But, don't worry.
We're just messing with you.
[ Zipper zips ]
This is our
real business.
We make these glorious
pants right here
that help save elephants.
These are our
harem pants.
A.K.A. the most comfortable
pants in the world.
M.C. Hammer
can't touch these.
[ Dance music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
I didn't expect that.
So, Sharks, who's ready
to join our herd
and help us save elephants
one leg at a time?
So, we got some samples
for you guys.
There you go, Robert.
Thank you.
Lori.
♪♪
They're cute.
So, why elephants?
So, yeah...
Tell the story.
...we've always
loved elephants as a kid.
You're brothers?
‐No.
No. We met in college.
College friends.
I went over
to Thailand in 2013,
um, to go do
the touristy things.
We went to
an elephant "sanctuary."
We didn't realize that
it was one of those
where they're beaten.
They're literally
in chains.
Like, when we walked in,
and they were
tied to trees in chains.
And that's no way that
an elephant should live.
And what is the amount
of the purchase
that goes back
to the elephants?
10% of net profits
are donated to ‐‐
That's really not
all that much, guys.
Oh, well, we've actually
donated about $115,000
to the African Wildlife
Foundation.
Well, good for you.
Okay, so, now
for the big question.
Who the hell wears this?
‐Uh...
‐Yeah.
Our core demo is
18‐ to 24‐year‐old females.
That's a big bulk and ‐‐
Well, men wear these, too.
Yeah.
Let met tell you something.
He wear‐‐ He wears
an obnoxious pair.
‐Oh, no. Here it comes.
‐When I ‐‐
Let me tell you a story.
Buddhist monks.
In the late '60s, my family
moved to Phnom Penh, Cambodia,
and I lived there for two years.
And Vietnamese fishing pants
became a standard for me.
They're worn by over 100 million
men. I'm one of them.
I have 40 pair.
I have to tell you,
I've seen them,
and they look horrible.
And what are your sales?
So, we've done $7 million
in the course of
the two years in business.
‐What's that?!
‐$7 million?!
‐You got to be kidding me!
‐Are you serious?
‐Good for you.
What does a pair cost?
$6,999,999.
[ Laughter ]
‐We sold one pair.
‐That was the gold pair.
Retails for $24,
and it's about $6 landed.
‐Where do you sell these goods?
‐Wow.
Uh, 95% of our sales come
from an e‐commerce website,
and then we've got
5% wholesale right now.
How do you get people
to your site?
‐So, all through our own site.
Uh, we have a pretty diverse,
uh, source of acquisition
and retention,
so we do a lot of ‐‐
So, tell us about that,
'cause that's the key, right?
Yeah.
So, yeah. I mean, we do a lot
of, um, Facebook advertising,
a lot of Social Grind.
Our Facebook is 230,000
followers, Instagram's 116,000.
Wow.
We look at influencers.
We look at
affiliate networks.
But what was the scaling point?
What makes it go boom?
‐Yeah. So ‐‐
‐To $7 million.
‐Yep. So about ‐‐
‐I mean, that's a staggering
number in two years.
So, four months later,
we started kicking out
Facebook advertising,
and, so, that is where
we started to see
that really strong growth
and continued.
And then, you just kept on
ramping it up, 'cause it worked.
Yep.
How much did you spend
on your advertising?
Last month, we did about
$430,000 in sales.
Okay.
Um, we spent about 75 ‐‐
$75,000 on advertising.
What do you want
the $500,000 for?
So, we're gonna use it
for investing more in marketing
but then also
strategic value
that all of you guys hold,
as well.
Guys, let me ‐‐
I applaud you.
It's ‐‐ It's one of
the best stories
we have ever seen out here.
I mean, to get to
$7 million, power to you.
Look, I've invested in stuff
that I won't necessarily use,
but I've got to
at least like the product.
I just don't see it. I'm out.
Okay. Appreciate it.
Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
I mean, it's unbelievable.
Thanks.
Guys, let me tell you
where I'm at.
Look, congratulations
on what you've done.
Thank you.
You've taken a cause,
you've ‐‐ you've
made it personal,
and you figured out
what your secret sauce is,
which is marketing.
The challenge for me
is that Facebook giveth,
Facebook can taketh away.
Right? Facebook has made
marketing companies millions,
and with one policy change,
those millions have disappeared.
And because of
that risk factor from Facebook,
I'm gonna say I'm out.
Guys, I like it.
I'm gonna make you two offers,
and you can choose
between them, okay?
I'm the most creative Shark
in terms of structure,
so the others
will learn from this.
So, I'm gonna offer you
[ Laughs ]
$500,000 as a line of credit,
and I'll take a 5% equity fee
to set it up.
The other offer is $500,000
for 20% equity.
Straight equity.
I'm the only Shark up here
that actually wears
those kinds of pants.
[ Laughter ]
And...
He is right about that.
...I would be
your top model.
[ Laughs ]
I can't wait
to see that.
Okay, guys. I'll give you
the offer $500,000 for 20%.
Appreciate that.
We appreciate your offer.
All right. So, there's
an offer from Daymond.
You got two equal offers,
but he also has
a different structure.
You know, I hate
cruelty to animals.
I would go in
with one of my fellow Sharks
if they want to make me
an offer to join in.
Would you consider to getting
two Sharks in the deal,
going with the line of credit,
12% interest rate,
and give us 10% equity,
you get two Sharks
and we go to town marketing this
for you, using our Shark power?
I will actually
allow myself
to be photographed
with Elephant Pants.
‐No!
‐You know, the big‐‐
the bigger problem is
millennials are buying it...
Don't do it.
... right, from you?
‐Yeah. They love them.
‐They don't want to see
Kevin in those.
This is true.
Greiner:
I'll do that deal.
Would the three of you
consider partnering together
at $500,000 for 15%?
So, 5% each?
To save the elephants?
Straight equity
or a line of credit?
‐Straight equity.
So you don't like
the line of credit?
'Cause that's what
they're offering.
Yeah, no.
We understand.
You don't like
the line of credit?
No, I don't think so.
If there's no line of credit,
you're not interested in that?
‐At this point,
we don't want to add
another liability.
Daymond, what do you
think of that?
I‐I mean, this is, uh,
you know, the space that
I've lived in for 25 years.
I just don't need their ‐‐
their help.
What would you do
for two of them?
Do $500,000 for 12%.
Ohh.
Is that enough for
the headaches this is gonna be?
Daymond, would you be willing
to do the $500,000 for 12%?
I respect ‐‐
I respect the counter.
I think that you always
should counter.
Um, I'll go to $500,000
for 17.5%
Ooh.
‐Hmm.
‐He rarely comes back.
Okay.
Thank you, Daymond.
Does this mean you're not
countering to us?
But I will still be at 17.5%.
We just want to understand
what you're doing here.
We just want to see, like,
what our options really are.
I‐I‐I will still stay at 17.5%.
The risk is
if you have no interest in
dealing with us as a team,
we can drop out, and then
you have less leverage.
That's the problem.
You got to be careful.
You're at that
really difficult place.
So, I ‐‐ I think we'll ‐‐ let's
handle one counter at a time.
[ Laughter ]
So, just counter
with Daymond first
and then let's ‐‐
Is this too serious
of a time for you
to do the Hammer‐thing
one last time?
Absolutely not.
We'll do it.
Whatever you guys want.
Ready?
‐I love it!
‐One, two, three.
My legs
almost fell asleep.
[ Dance music plays ]
[ Laughter ]
I got ‐‐ I got to be partners
with these guys.
I got to be partners
Whichever Shark they get
has to do the dance.
‐All day.
‐You're right.
That's part of the deal.
It's part of the deal.
All right. All right.
You are at $500,000 for 12%.
I was at 20%.
17.5%, and I will
fund production.
That's where I'm at.
‐Okay, thank you, Daymond.
‐Guys, that's a good offer.
So, Kevin and I
just talked.
We're out.
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
James and Nathan have
one offer on the table.
$500,000 for 17.5%
from Daymond
for their clothing company,
Elephant Pants.
Daymond,
would you do 15%?
‐Oh. That just took me up to ‐‐
‐You're a smart guy.
‐Yeah. That was.
‐Yeah. I was at 17.5%.
What's your concern, um,
'cause now they're out?
And now, I'm ‐‐
I'm the elephant in the room.
‐Just a fair val‐‐
Really, it's a fair valuation
for the company
and also
the other partners.
Um, yes, we own
the majority share,
but we also want to make sure
we respect their equity stakes
in the business, as well,
so that we're getting
a fair valuation.
Do 2% advisory shares.
If you're worried about other
investors and how it hits
anything there,
do 2% in advisory shares
so that your numbers
hit the way you need them.
I'm confident the 5% difference
of where you were at,
I'm confident I'm gonna grow
that company more than 5%.
Is that what you're saying,
you're gonna stay at 17.5%?
Well, would you do 15%
with 2.5% advisory shares?
‐Those are options.
‐Yeah.
No. They ‐‐
They vest, right?
Once they vest,
you're owned, right?
They're not options.
It's Daymond's money.
‐They're shares.
‐Right.
They're shares.
He can structure it
any way he wants.
Greiner: He's the only elephant
left in the room.
They're saying
they can do the deal.
They just want to
not have to deal with
their other partners
and explain the valuation.
Yeah, at the end of the day,
long as I'm gonna end up
with 17.5%.
Yeah.
Okay.
We good?
Let's save some elephants!
All right, Daymond.
We got a deal!
Let's do it.
Let's Hammer dance.
‐All right!
‐Let's Hammer dance.
You ready for the dance?
You gonna do it?
‐Yeah.
‐Let's do it.
All right.
One, two, three, go.
[ Laughter ]
‐Yep.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Congratulations.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you.
‐Seriously, guys, thank you.
We really appreciate it.
‐Bye, elephant.
‐Good luck.
Greiner: Bye.
Here's the real
important point.
There's 350,000 people
that are wearing these!
[ Both grunt ]
Striking a deal
with Daymond
is gonna bring our company
from here up to here.
I mean, he's really gonna
help us drive long‐term sales
and grow our brand
into a household name.
And, not only that, but we get
to save a lot more elephants.
And elephants get
to keep their own ivory.
Boom!